[Music]
yeah sub at fence
you're watching Gotham cribs and today
I'm taking you on a sick tour of Wayne
Manor let's go the most tasteful and
insanely extravagant mansion in all of
Gotham City
[Music]
when I pulled on the line
[Music]
and for those of you wondering yes the
rumors are true I am Bruce Wayne
roommate and speaking of old Bruno I
think I see my roomie right over there
yo be money what's up my billionaire
playboy hey Batman thanks for being such
a great host an iconic superhero I'm
privileged to know you
now let's uh let's start the tour here
we have the kitchen it's filled with
state-of-the-art appliances and cooking
devices like um this thing and that
thing or this guy over here yeah
cooking rules and in the fridge we got
plenty of delicious dishes like Lobster
Thermidor
my favorite oh yeah oh that's good stuff
I love it so b-dubs had to take a quick
business call now who wants to see the
pool majestic right and yes those are
actual dolphins Wow
can you believe this I mean what kind of
guy has dolphins for pets someone who's
crazy wealthy stupid good-looking but
it's also just a down-to-earth rat dude
am i right I'm sorry did I hear someone
say rat dude that tends to happen a lot
around me so it makes sense now let me
show you the rest of the bad this is my
bad room where I catch up on my sleep I
never sleep because I'm too busy
fighting criminals and saving Gotham
City 24/7 but I can see how a room like
this would make sense for most people
it's going finally here we have my
secret room
every good looking mysterious
billionaire bachelor has one
unfortunately I can't show you mine
because it's super 100% top-secret but
crazy awesome
Alfred hello master Blanton my name is
Batman so can you please call me Batman
thank you very much of course sir
your son Robin and I were just doing the
light dusting around the bat super
secret man cave hi dad yet that's all
the time we have hope you enjoyed this
sick episode of Garvin cribs Batman out
Wyn PG being a part of a family again
no now it's snake clouds because you put
that idea in my it sir you need to take
responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising the young off